what up space fam golsan here from anime
uproar and we finally got another
chapter one punch man and i loved it had
many amazing moments so make sure to
stay tuned for this one if you do enjoy
seeing these one punch man videos and
want to keep them coming then the best
thing you could do is channel the
saitama within and one punch that like
button remember that smashing that like
button is s-class energy and passing is
fear ugly energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one punch man videos and updates and
while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my growing
one punch man playlist that includes
videos on all the s-class heroes dragon
and god level monsters and much more
link to that is in the description and
now without further ado let's jump into
its spoilers and all i love the cover
page here as we got bang and bomb
chilling out and staring at the clouds
we're told unfulfilled dreams come with
youth wandering thoughts come with age i
absolutely love that line there's a much
more chilled out and at peace quality
when it comes to these two old
characters especially when you compare
them to someone young like garu it's
also super relevant because we will get
to see the younger versions of these two
in this chapter and i can't wait to get
to that however for now we got bang and
garo fighting even though the idea was
brought up before a bomb being stronger
than bang it's clear that bang is doing
better than bomb was here whether that
has to do with bomb's old age or garo
going easier on his former master is not
clear story wise it's great though
because obviously there is much more
meaning behind this fight between these
two former master and student than there
would be between bomb and garo garo
takes up a stance to the shock of the
others and they realize its explosion
release fist a technique that bang
sealed off long ago for people who read
the webcomic and think that they don't
need to read the manga this is another
prime example of how the two can be very
different not only are the illustrations
next level but new stuff is added or
changed all the time like this very
intriguing backstory of bang and the
explosion fist which by the way matches
his name bang beautifully we're told
that when garl was fleeing he broke into
the dojo and looked at the scrolls bang
ensured he couldn't escape with them but
garo being the genius he is got a grasp
of it with just one read furthermore
bang calls it a wicked technique which
adds the curiosity even more so this is
perfect characterization time for bang
here as he says to think i'd have to
settle things with garo as well as with
my past self at the same time he's even
more certain that he must not lose now
we then get the much needed and
appreciated backstory that will probably
shock a lot of us that bang used to be
an out of control ruffian in his youth
in fact he's almost a spitting image of
garo in the flashback in looks and
behavior he challenged anyone who looked
strong and sent them to the hospital he
also had such a smug smirk on his face
the perfect cocky douchebag expression i
must say he was drowning in martial arts
talent we're told which is a fantastic
way of putting it and he clearly had
girls and money to go with it he was the
picture of carnal desires rather than
discipline he enjoyed martial arts by
doing what he felt like and when his
brother tried to talk some sense into
him bang said his big bro was getting
bald because he was so rock headed we're
reintroduced to young bang as explosion
released fist wind of blood bang which
by the way how awesome is that name this
is making me love bang all the more
knowing he had this interesting
backstory his big bro let him know that
he was losing hair because of stress and
said he's here to cut the stress off at
the source which is obviously his out of
control little brother by the way bomb's
full title was whirlwind iron cutting
fist wind of death bomb another cool
name definitely a very cool family
overall bomb challenges bang telling him
his rampage will end here and as bang
shoots away the girls he prepares to
fight bang tells his brother that his
die hard training day in and day out is
absurd believing that he is unbeatable
because he's a guy with good taste
having fun not sure if i ever heard that
reason for being unbeatable but
interesting nonetheless it's a clear
conflict between discipline committing
to a process whether you like it or not
and bang's fun approach which includes
using power to just enjoy oneself that
way even though he's doing constant
martial arts by beating people up he has
zero stress according to him his form of
martial arts is pretty much losing
himself in fighting people again
emphasizing his lack of discipline bomb
even says bang thinks he gains so much
power but he hasn't even overcome
himself and then he says he'll teach him
a lesson about that and lo and behold
discipline in mastering one's desires
wins out bomb badly defeats bang and i
guess it's not a surprise since clearly
balding is a sign of strength in one
punch man just look at saitama bang
understood that while his fist was
filled with killing intent his brother
had none and yet bang still lost that's
how outmatched he was and how inferior
his so-called training was to bombs he
could sense that he lost because he was
too close-minded in his ways and needed
to be more broad-minded he sealed off
the explosion release fist and trained
many years now like bomb not against
opponents per se but with himself and
thus was born the ultimate defense of
art the water stream rock smashing fist
like his brother he opened the dojo and
his brother was glad to see it i love
the brother dynamic here by the way it's
absolutely awesome and bomb lets us know
that bang became a hero despite having
no interest in it sort of telling bomb
that he's reformed himself he's no
longer a dude who just does what he
feels like when bomb heard about bang
trying to confront a former student he
felt like bang was trying to do exactly
what bomb did for him trying to reform
his student rather than just destroy him
and i think this makes so much more
sense now now that we got this backstory
it really helped flesh out bang's
motivation otherwise it would have been
hard to believe he'd be so willing to go
easy on garo in the past and give him
chance after chance if he wasn't in the
exact same situation before and had
someone to help reform him he's more
certain that he can reform garo because
he was garo in the past or at least very
similar to him bomb wanted to help
worried that bang's resolve might be
misplaced bang insisted that this was
between master and student and so bam
made up the excuse that garo may go
after his dojo to join his brother as
his elder brother bomb followed what he
felt was his duty and i gotta say i have
a newfound appreciation for his
character too after all of this new
information very good chapter in that
sense in the present bomb sees that bang
is being overwhelmed but he also sees
that garo's technique is incomplete he
thinks that bang's only chance is the
explosion release fist but bang doesn't
use it when he gets the opening he is
officially a man of principles now not
willing to win if it means winning the
wrong way and embracing the past he's
renounced and bomb smiles seeing how far
bang has come and that he is in fact
fully reformed in a far cry from the man
he used to be i did wonder why explosion
fist would work against garo potentially
if it didn't even work against bomb in
the past but perhaps bomb's technique
was more complete and he didn't allow
any openings for it to be used as garo
does bang gets smashed to the ground and
he's clearly very beat up and sweaty but
he doesn't give up and even says looks
like i'm getting through watch carefully
big bro end quote it's a
goosebump-inducing moment but also kind
of funny because you're thinking how
does he know it's getting through to
garo when gar was beating him up
mercilessly but you know that bang knows
what he's talking about when it comes to
martial arts and fighting bomb says yeah
he's watching and he sees a twisted punk
that has improved splendidly obviously
referring to bang and that fact alone
gives them both hope that garo might not
be too far gone either bang continues
fighting and i love the fact that he's
communicating through his fists he says
anyone of garo's level of talent should
be able to hear the voice of his fists
and understand him the love for martial
arts in general is really coming through
in this chapter bang acknowledges his
faults he failed as a master and let the
hero world distract him away from the
relationship with his students and so
garo went down the wrong path then his
students left the dojo and garo caused
trouble for so many heroes bang blames
himself for all of it and that's why
this battle is so significant to him
he's trying to right all of garo's
wrongs and his own and then he drops the
bang show he says after this incident
he'll retire from being a hero so we
have the end of s-class hero rank 3 bang
insane and even if he does stop being a
hero i really hope he'll stay in the
story love this character so much bang's
plan is to go back to him and garo being
master and disciple and this time he
won't let stuff like being a hero come
in the way it really does seem like he's
getting through togaro in a sense as
garo's shell literally starts cracking
we then again see genos getting wrecked
by black asses and tatsumaki too
tatsumaki seems totally powerless to do
anything at this point not even move
genos for his part only manages to get
rid of three black s's while there's
almost 4.5 billion left and i assume
that's not counting the much stronger
golden s either that absorbed a bunch of
them the situation is hopeless as far as
genos can tell he shows that he's grown
as a character too though despite not
being able to overpower the black s's
and says before he would have
self-destructed despite the heroes
around but now he uses the strength he
has left to cover and protect tatsumaki
he feels like he's not becoming stronger
because he's getting wrecked by his
enemies but still respect for his
selfless actions and for protecting
others like a true hero up to what as
far as he's concerned could be his very
last moment then as it looks like the
black s's are about to finish them off
suddenly some light appears in the
distance and surprises the black s's
which in my view must be saitama blast
and flashy flash coming to the rescue it
would definitely be perfect timing for
that but let me know if you think it
might be something else anyways wow
great chapter but the next one should be
even more hype with saitama showing up
and perhaps even blasts stopping by as
he drops them off it's definitely about
time for them to show up but they've
definitely done a good job of keeping it
interesting before they got here as well
but anyways let me know what you thought
of this chapter and what you are most
looking forward to seeing happening next
who was your mvp this time around
obviously if anyone says genos i get it
he deserved it too but i gotta give it
to bang his effort and character arc
it's been amazing learning more about
him this chapter if you did enjoy this
video and want to keep them coming you
know what to do channel the saitama
within and one punch that like button
remember smashing that like button is
s-class energy and passing is pure ugly
energy so choose wisely don't be if
you're ugly if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future one punch man videos and updates
and while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my growing
one punch man playlist that includes
videos on all the s-class heroes dragon
and god level monsters and much more
link to that is in the description leave
any suggestions for other one punch man
topics you'd like me to cover below in
the comments and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you